Welcome back everyone this is my full marvel what
if episode 7 video for the party version of thor
so we'll break it all down there's a bunch of
easter eggs and obviously they set up the big
multiverse crossover with a multiverse version of
the avengers team the guardians of the multiverse
at the end of the episode as well if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the episodes they are going to be doing what if
season two it'll also be nine episodes so i'll
start talking about that after the finale in a
couple weeks we also have all the hawkeye episodes
that will be starting after what if i'll be doing
episode videos for that as well too careful for
spoilers if you have not seen the episode yet
starting with the episode title what if thor
were an only child examining how loki affected his
development as a character when they were growing
up or how he didn't affect him because obviously
this version of loki grew up on yodenheim
you could also think of it as the thor vs captain
marvel episode for those of you that ever wanted
to see the two of them fight like what would that
look like how would that go down i will talk about
that too because that's obviously a big question
who is the most powerful avenger and don't worry
i will explain what happened at the end of the
episode with this infinity gauntlet final boss
form version of ultron if it wasn't clear he is
meant to be the main villain of the what if series
but the opening scene starts with the same
opening scene from the first thor movie in
the desert with jane foster and darcy in the rv
researching anomalies in wormholes waiting for
the bifrost to dump thor in the desert only this
time because events have changed because the big
nexus event it takes him somewhere else and for
the most part pretty much everybody from the thor
movies and even the guardians of the galaxy movies
came back to do their characters from the movies
chris hemsworth is playing thor tom hiddleston
was playing loki again he already came back for
what if episode 3 for that version of loki in the
other universe that wound up conquering earth kat
dennings came back as darcy natalie portman came
back as jane foster pretty much everybody from
thor ragnarok like jeff goldblum came back as the
grand master even karen gillan came back as nebula
seth green came back as howard the duck samuel l
jackson clark gregg kobe smolders all came back as
their characters taika wattini came back as korg
even clancy brown came back as serter but jane
foster tries to call nick fury and shield talking
about alien invasion they hang up on her because
they initially don't believe her and nick fury's
kind of already aware of aliens to begin with
it's a bit of a slight reference to the scrolls
secret invasion from the captain marvel movies
foreshadowing later in the episode when they
pull out captain marvel's pager and party thor
meets other versions of scrolls from outer
space when she says two years ago the same
anomaly struck star alpha icarus and destroyed it
that's all foreshadowing for thor explaining how
his other party previously wound up destroying
another planet although the way he explained it
the planet was already in the process of getting
ready to be destroyed by a giant meteorite and
they were just celebrating the end of that world
or the impending end of that world with a giant
party so their party itself did not destroy the
planet it was already going to be destroyed but
her referencing the energy of the bifrost being
present during the destruction of that planet
is also a reference to the first thor movie when
loki tried to use the bifrost to destroy yodenheim
and then the big change to this scene from the
first thor movie is that instead of the bifrost
dumping him in the desert where they are here and
then running him over with the car it dumps him
in las vegas and they play it like thor arriving
in wakanda during avengers infinity war his big
scene of showing up with stormbreaker but the
big record drop joke here is that he announces
himself as the party prince of the universe and
he's here to rock their world metaphorically with
a huge party he shows up with the warriors three
in tow who also start rocking out in the middle
of a random crowd and then the watcher appears
in an even bigger way than in previous episodes
like i said this has been a running theme the
past several episodes where the watcher slowly
manifests more and more like he's appearing closer
and closer to the characters in every episode
but then as he's done in previous episodes the
watcher sort of narrates the main mcu timeline
version of events just to set up how things
are different and what the big nexus event was
in this universe that caused everything to go down
differently and it's just a way of showing you how
important loki was in shaping who thor became one
of my few complaints about the episode though is
that it actually feels like they're almost closer
as bros in this episode like brothers from another
mother like friends they're almost closer than
they felt like they were in the main mcu movies
like wait what in talking about loki easter eggs
here from the loki series the major nexus event of
this alternate universe was that originally when
odin defeated lafee loki's father and pushed the
frost giants back to jodenheim when he found baby
loki left out in the cold to die instead of taking
him and raising him as his own son to maintain
this peace treaty between the asgardians and the
frost giants he took the baby back to laufey to be
raised in the traditional manner a prince of the
frost giants would have been so this loki grows up
to be a regular looking very tall frost giant one
of the other continuity mistakes i think though
is the idea that laufey would take baby loki back
the whole idea was that he didn't want baby loki
like laufey didn't lose baby loki he literally put
him there so that he would die there are a couple
minor continuity issues that i've noticed with the
what if series also talk about this when i talk
about what's going on with the infinity gauntlet
version of ultron because there's a big continuity
error there even though some of these things are
relatively minor and they didn't bother me that
much but you do kind of notice them there have
been continuity errors in the live-action marvel
movies all the time like the whole timeline error
that they made during spider-man homecoming with
that eight years card so then they pick up during
the events of the first thor movie when odin
is getting ready to go into the odin sleep and
regenerate his life force the odin force frigga
pieces out saying that she's gonna go visit her
sisters frigga is actually from vanaheim she's
the daughter of the king of the vanir there was
a joke about a history lesson going on at the end
of the episode cool marvel history lesson in real
life about how asgard was formed or at least the
backstory of asgard bore who we saw during thor
of the dark world was born in the kingdom of the
aesir when boer eventually took the throne from
their father one of his brothers split off to form
his own kingdom and named it vanaheim that's the
planet that they're on at the beginning of thor
the dark world after a couple wars between he and
his brother their different kingdoms board decided
to bring their people back together reunite their
people because they came from the same race using
a marriage alliance between his son odin and the
daughter of his brother the king of the van near
freyja so when odin eventually took the throne
from bore they basically combined all their
people the vanir in the aesir and they became
the asgardians naming the new kingdom asgard even
though some of the vanir still live on vanaheim
not everybody moved to the new asgardian homeworld
when it was formed maybe in a future marvel movie
we'll hear more about frigga and odin's backstory
but in the episode when odin goes into the odin's
sleep as freyja says thor becomes proxy king of
asgard in his absence which is basically what was
going to happen at the beginning of the first thor
movie anyway until loki pulls his prank allowing
the frost giants to invade to interrupt his big
day just to take the piss out of him a little
but there's no loki here this time to do that
so thor becomes king without any kind of effort
or trouble but they go past odin's vault walk
past the now fake infinity gauntlet as we know
it claiming that he's going to throw a party on
earth he's not going to be a boring king like odin
because heimdall won't care about earth because
it's such a backwater planet little does thor
know there are actually a couple infinity stones
on planet earth right now then big easter egg for
thor ragnarok the bottomless mugs that doctor
strange gave him to drink from with the beer
he passes them all mugs claiming later that they
will never be empty because magic they all refill
themselves i'm not gonna name every single
character in the background here i feel like
it's enough to say that pretty much every single
major character even some of the background ones
come from thor ragnarok from the guardians of
the galaxy movies some of the bigger ones i'll
point out though like here scourge shows up but
it's not carl urban because he doesn't have any
speaking lines same thing with valkyrie later in
the episode and some of the other guardians of
the galaxy characters like nebula is one of the
only guardians that actually has speaking lines
and it was karen gillen that came back to do
her voice there are scrolls hanging out in the
background that thor talks to later that changed
themselves into versions of thor they weren't
secretly hiding on planet earth though because you
can see they're wearing their normal spacesuits
even though some scrolls were on planet earth
during this period they'll get into that during
the secret invasion series next year in captain
marvel 2. then jane foster winds up introducing
herself to thor and they play it kind of like they
did during the first thor movie when they met for
the first time like them being super surprised
by how good looking he is darcy then makes fun of
howard the duck calling him a loser who's retorted
to make fun of her for being a brunette apparently
howard the duck is not a fan of brunettes but i
think that's all a misdirect because later they
wind up getting married married in vegas on the
spot as you do when you're super drunk and as far
as we know they're still married at the end of
the episode mrs howard the duck not now howard
when thor makes the joke about horse gods in
norse mythology in real life loki did turn
himself into a female horse to mate with another
male horse and create odin's eight-legged horse
that's right obviously they didn't do that in the
mcu but they do reference a lot of loki gender
flipping and pansexuality during the loki series
which is sort of a wink at the norse mythology
stories about loki thor explains their party on
that destroyed planet alpha star and i do kind
of wonder now what happened to fandral's goat gary
where did that wind up darcy's not a date moment
with howard the duck is also similar to the joke
on wand division where she almost went on a date
with vision there was the scene where mind control
darcy is inside the hex thinking vision is trying
to hit on her and just reluctantly agrees to go
on a date with him before she remembers who she is
jeff goldblum's grandmaster djs the party it
turns into an even bigger rave nebula tries to
gamble to win some money for a new cybernetic
eye most of this is all pretty light stuff all
just played for comedy before the episode was
released the showrunner said that they meant
for this episode to be much less tragic than the
doctor strange episode ending even though they had
a big ending which was kind of a doubter like
oh no spoke too soon looks like we're going to
fubar this universe too overall the episode had a
fairly light tone thor and jane foster's tattoos
are meant to be a big reference for the first thor
movie when thor was explaining how magic was just
advanced science that humans did not understand
yet and because natalie portman's jane foster is
also going to become a version of female thor in
thor love and thunder you could call her tattoo of
thor's hammer and easter egg for that as well the
next morning everybody has hangovers waking up in
a vegas hotel and shield starts blowing up their
phones crossbones knocking their door down with
maria hill we see rocket raccoon finally make an
appearance in an episode he wasn't in the t'challa
star-lord episode with the guardians of the galaxy
for whatever reason thor also refers to this
version of rocket raccoon as a cute little rabbit
just like he called him during avengers infinity
war maria hill explains what happened to nick fury
do you know why i'm the director of shield right
now because korg wound up plowing through nick
fury doing a cannonball into the fountain so he's
still out cold clark greg came back as coulson
and the way he explains it his sort of chart here
makes it sound like the party itself is kind of
like a cancer spreading all over the planet like
for a little while in the episode they make it
seem like thor's party might actually destroy the
planet then they set up the whole captain marvel
twist with them revealing to jane foster nope this
is not the first time we have met aliens because
pager and even though they don't say it in the
episode odin and his father before him bore would
have visited earth many times in ancient history
being worshipped as gods by norse people germanic
tribes for thousands and thousands of years before
this really good example is that odin knows about
the eternals that's how long he's been around so
aliens have visited earth long before the events
of the captain marvel movie and because the what
if series is meant to be canon to the mcu i'm also
assuming that if she knew about the pager during
this then the main mcu version of maria hill also
probably knew about nick fury's souped-up space
pager when they jump to paris france you see thor
hanging out with a couple of the sovereign rays
from guardians of the galaxy 2. we'll see them
again during guardians 3 like ayesha will come
back in guardians 3 because they have to pay off
the whole atom warlock guardians of the galaxy 2
post-credits scene we finally get to see frost
giant loki in full attire wearing an ice crown
denoting his position as prince of the frost
giants just as thor is currently king of asgard
he calls thor the son of a witch because frigga
is a witch in the mcu it's also a reference to
thor ragnarok when thor joked that loki dressed
like a witch and like i said earlier the big
second record drop moment of the episode is
that even though they grew up separately they
still think of each other as unofficial brothers
like they're just as close as bros as they were
as real brothers and even though the boom joke is
all about captain marvel showing up thor does make
kind of a joke when he says i only boom in private
then because of the era that captain marvel comes
from she calls thor white snake because all of her
references are from the 80s and 90s like it's her
version of calling him point break the way that
iron man called him point break because of the
way he looks because of his hairdo then they have
their big thor vs captain marvel throwdown fight
in them getting into it i think it's meant to pay
off that brief teaser from avengers end game when
they meet and it just seems like for a hot second
thor might pick a fight with her but they don't
like what would it look like if thor fought
captain marvel a lot of people were wondering
this when avengers end game came out because
they're both supposed to be some of the most
powerful avengers and as you see in the episode
it's kind of like watching thor fight the hulk
just a couple of beings that can both soak a ton
of physical damage and energy damage so the fights
theoretically would just drag on forever unless
one of them had a special weapon to power them up
even more or one of them just made an error during
the fight like you go to watch a big boxing match
in vegas except their fight takes place all over
planet earth because they punch each other with
so much force he knocks her all the way into
stonehenge from paris and then knocks all the
stones down when captain marvel claims that no
one knows what stonehenge is that's actually not
true currently the prevailing scientific theory
just based on all the evidence is that ancient
neolithic britons created the site together like
many different tribes of ancient britons created
it together not just the druids and it was created
to serve many different functions like it was
both a sacred burial site a religious holy place
that people took pilgrimages to a ceremonial site
and a place for burying royalty and high-ranking
members of tribes of that era captain marvel winds
up pulling the same trick that iron man did during
the thor vs iron man fight in the first avengers
movie where she winds up using all the lightning
energy from the hammer to power herself up then
thor gets the upper hand on her using the same
trick back in vegas that he used on loki during
the first thor movie just putting the hammer on
top of her body to keep her from being able to
move and she's not powerful enough to counter the
force of odin's enchantment the only way someone
who's not worthy could lift it would be if they
had magic powerful enough to break odin's spell on
it like doctor strange jokes in thor ragnarok that
he can't pick it up like he's not that powerful
but i do think though early theory that scarlet
witch could probably break odin's enchantment
with her chaos magic just because of the way they
explain chaos magic being so op in the mcu don't
worry we'll talk more about that kind of stuff
during doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness when
we get the first trailer for that when captain
marvel goes back to the helicarrier they reference
goose the cat or the florkin because it's not a
cat technically maria hill saying that she has a
cat that can devour whole armies darcy understands
the top gun reference making even more top gun
jokes about her being maverick reciting lines from
the movie then the whole thing about her not using
her full power because it would destroy part of
the earth that actually is true technically she
could go binary which we have not seen yet in the
mcu movies we might see that during captain marvel
2. it's like a final boss form version of captain
marvel that she can take where she becomes as
powerful like her energy output becomes as
powerful as a binary star that's why her name
when she does this is binary they also kind of
shame jane foster for sleeping with thor telling
her that you're not helping at all dump her back
on the ground where howard the duck comes back to
remind darcy that they're still married to make
as many duck puns as possible that duck sure does
get a lot of tail then they get the bright idea to
call thor's mother on him because he gave them the
idea earlier when he explained how frigga was the
only one who was powerful enough to discipline him
as a child besides odin because of her magic and
even though they haven't really gotten into this
in the mcu yet frigga is kind of a hardcore
shield maiden too like she's just as strong
a fighter as odin is she's not quite as strong
as thor or the hulk but still very very strong
darcy makes a he-man and the masters of the
universe reference when they're naming off all the
other major asgardians like odin frigga heimdall
and all the other aliens just wind up trashing
the entire planet vandalizing all the major
monuments setting up the big montage they have
at the end of the episode even clancy brown shows
up as certain for that funny scene with a statue
of liberty thinking that it's a real woman after
jane foster shouts so loud that heimdall notices
he uses the bifrost to send her to vanaheim to
alert frigga who explains everything about what's
been going on in the whole subplot here about
maria hill wanting to use the nukes on thor and
captain marvel is also a reference to the nuclear
warhead from the first avengers movie the world
security council was going to destroy new york
city with collateral damage using a nuclear strike
just so that they could close the tesseract
portal and it probably would not have worked
when maria hill claims captain marvel would be
fine in the blast she is kind of correct captain
marvel would be able to absorb the nuclear
radiation as energy but the concussive force
of the blast would probably knock her out cold for
at least a week when thor asked captain marvel to
smile that's also a reference to a scene from the
captain marvel movie friga winds up using the same
trick that heindall used during avengers infinity
war when he sent the hulk back to warn doctor
strange using dark magic to open a bifrost portal
instead of using their regular technology nebula
winds up referencing thanos when everyone starts
to bail on him i think i hear my dad calling later
but they have their cleaning montage and then
captain marvel helps thor make it look like he
was telling the truth about the cultural exchange
like she does give him an ipad with a bunch of
information on earth so that thor can learn more
about earth's culture and the reason why frigga
knew all about captain marvel like i know who
you are is because odin and frigga the asgardians
have been monitoring earth for thousands of years
for example like i said odin knows all about the
eternals they know everything major that's been
going on on midgard they end the episode kind
of in the same way that they end the first thor
movie with thor and jane becoming a little more
serious about their relationship like it's gonna
become a bigger thing the planet of unicorns that
he promises to take her to is actually a thing
from the comics planet unicorn is a miss marvel
reference i guess because we have captain marvel
here in this episode and we're getting the miss
marvel series early next year but in the comics
miss marvel writes this fan fiction story about
the avengers fighting together on a planet of
unicorns in the funny way they play this ending
record drop moment is they make it seem like the
happy ending is the actual record drop when really
it is ultron showing up with all the infinity
stones but they play the sappy love music as
the watcher narrates they lived happily ever after
but then he's like wait what you know big record
drop moment as ultron steps through the portal
from the multiverse with his ultron robots with
all six infinity stones and vision's body as if he
has somehow become a living infinity gauntlet like
final boss form ultron from another universe so if
you haven't been watching my other what if videos
i've been saying this for a while now this is
meant to be a big crossover series with the other
universe versions of characters from different
episodes crossing over in a big multiverse
avengers team up for the finale but while this is
happening while they're fighting ultron and his
army marvel zombies are also supposed to come back
so i will do a separate video about this talking
about final boss form ultron with the infinity
stones and what's happening in the actual finale
my full marvel what if episode 8 video will post
next week just like normal and if you spotted any
other big easter eggs or references in the episode
that i didn't talk about in the video just write
them below in the comments everyone click here
for my brand new eternals trailer video for a kit
harrington's black knight character and click here
for my what if trailer video for the final two
episodes thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next video!